una de las consecuencias del cese de
relaciones fue el aumento de la
actividad de los grupos al margen de la
ley a ambos lados de la frontera cómo
puede cambiar ese hecho con este nuevo
anuncio
bien el anuncio desde luego que trae
esperanza en materia de esa cooperación
y más que cooperación comunicación es va
a ser muy difícil por supuesto que se
establezca una cooperación de buenas a
primeras
tomando en consideración que durante
mucho tiempo los dos ejércitos las dos
fuerzas armadas se vieron como rivales
se han visto históricamente como rivales
y en los últimos años también incluso
como enemigos tomando en consideración
la postura que se ha mantenido de un
lado del otro sin embargo dada que puede
haber comunicación en este caso de una
comunicación fluida y autorizada por los
gobiernos es posible que se pueda tener
un mejor monitoreo de los que son más de
2.200 kilómetros en donde solamente y 8
pasos oficiales pero se estima que puede
haber cientos no oficiales
y uno de los grupos que actúa en esta
zona fronteriza es el ejército de
liberación nacional lln y el gobierno de
gustavo petro buscará la paz con esta
guerrilla sirve también está anuncio
como medida de presión al ln
creo que más que el anuncio militar el
anuncio hacia la ln tiene que ser
político desde luego en materia del
anuncio militar por supuesto que lo pone
en alerta sabiendo que va a haber
cooperación entre las dos fuerzas
armadas pero lo más importante insisto
va a ser la comunicación política dado
que se estima que el gobierno de nicolás
maduro pueda tener algún grado de
incidencia de influencia en los procesos
de toma de decisión de ln creo que el
gobierno cubano podría tener mucho más
por supuesto pero siendo venezuela un
territorio en donde se supone que el de
se le ha dado cierta acogida al ln pues
tendrá caracas también algo que decir en
todo esto por lo tanto creo que todos
estos intercambios toda esta
comunicación parece ir orientado no
solamente a el restablecimiento y
normalización de las relaciones
fronterizas sino fundamentalmente a
potenciales procesos de paz y este
restablecimiento de relaciones militares
se une como usted ha dicho pues a la
intención de retomar relaciones
diplomáticas ya la reapertura de la
frontera que podría aportar el
acercamiento a la migración venezolana
en colombia
pues lo primero y más fundamental desde
luego es la apertura no solamente la
embajada sino más importante que ellos
los consulados la población venezolana
que es de acuerdo a la migración
colombia se estima que puede ya haber
superado los dos millones dos millones
cuatrocientos mil venezolanos en
territorio colombiano requiere por
supuesto de asistencia consular para sus
documentos para su vida cotidiana para
mantener entonces digamos un flujo
normal sobre toda esa población que
emigra pendularmente mantener también
control sobre sus bienes que mantiene
todavía algunos en venezuela- entonces
hay ahora una dinámica social
completamente nueva a partir de esto y
hace falta por supuesto esa asistencia
consular y del lado colombiano esa
participación esa asistencia consular
también es importante porque en la
medida en la cual se pueda identificar
plenamente los venezolanos pues habrá
mejores mecanismos de control sabiendo
que ha habido algunas controversias con
respecto a
actividades ilícitas en donde podrían
estar y donde se ha demostrado que ha
estado involucrados algunos migrantes
venezolanos